Problem number 32.
A scale drawing of a horse
is shown below.
That's the horse.
I'm probably not helping
you much at this point.
What is the actual height of the
horse in inches, from the
hoof to the top of the head?
Well, they made a little
scale for us.
This distance right
here is 8 inches.
And then they measure this
scale multiple times.
So how many times are we
going this distance?
We go 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
So the horse is 9 times this
distance, which is 8 inches.
Which is equal to 72 inches.
So that's how tall the
horse is in reality.
Which is what?
It's like 6 feet tall.
33.
A shipping company has 25
offices that shipped 60,000
packages last week.
The offices were open 6 days and
used 80,000 kilowatt-hours
of electricity.
Which pieces of information
given above are necessary to
find the average number
of packages shipped
per day last week?
So let's think about it.
They didn't ask us anything
about electricity.
So we definitely don't need
that information.
And they're saying the average
number of packages shipped per
day last week.
They're not saying per day
per office last week.
So we don't need to know
how many offices.
We just need to know that 60,000
packages were shipped
last week, and the offices
were open 6 days.
So they operated for 6 days.
So we could figure
out the answer.
The answer is obviously
10,000.
But they're not asking
us that.
They're asking us, what
information do we need?
We need the total number of
packages shipped last week,
and we need the number of days
that the office was open.
So what choices are that?
The number of offices-- no, we
don't need the number of
offices, because they didn't
ask us per office.
The number of packages and the
amount of electricity?
No.
This has nothing to do
with electricity.
The number of packages and
the number of days
open during the week?
Yeah, that's what we used.
The number of packages and
the number of days
open during the week.
The number of days open during
the week and the amount of
electricity?
No, this had nothing to do
with the electricity.
So our choice is C.
Problem 34.
A landscaper estimates that
landscaping a new park will
take 1 person 48 hours.
If 4 people work on the job,
and they each work 6-hour
days, how many days are needed
to complete the job?
If 1 person takes 48 hours,
4 people are going
to take 1/4 as long.
So 48 divided by 4 is going
to be equal to 12 hours.
If 4 people are each working
12 hours, that's the same
thing as 1 person working 48
hours, assuming that you could
divide the job up in that way.
So these 4 people are going to
take 12 hours, all working
simultaneously, and they each
worked 6-hour days.
So they're going to work a total
of 12 hours, because
there's 4 of them, so they can
take 1/4 of the time, but they
can only do 6 hours per day.
So it's going to take them 2
days to work their 12 hours.
It's going to take 2 days
to complete the job.
And that's all we have
on that page.